brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com alright that was the ubisoft
press conference right here at e3 2015
and let's start talking about what we
saw right at the end it looks like ghost
recons back for the first time in a long
time since advanced warfighter two with
a Ghost Recon wildlands go ahead Ghost
Recon you know on online yes teacher so
libs yeah oh yeah future soldiers love
it we've had a few actually my apologies
hey what do you think about why Lance
from what we saw it's from just fresh
off so this is their Just Cause II we
were we were saying while we were
watching it looked a bit far right mmm
it had like a touch of watch dogs with
the end very end yeah I'm saying quite
quite is almost like mercenaries co-op
Kevin a little bit yeah it was very
explodey yeah in that sense so we know
so far I guess is that this is an
open-world co-op game but with specific
missions as well yeah this drug lab
setup here was what they sort of focused
on um Alexa any thoughts on what we've
seen here in terms of like what this
might be in terms of a grander game
because all the showing here I guess as
a bunch of dudes going in to shoot a
bunch of other dudes like how do you
Heather how do you think this looks
differently to other yeah Ubisoft
shooters ah I don't think it does like
I'm seeing far cry I'm seeing um like
some watchdog elements i think it's sort
of an amalgam of everything that they've
been exploring with other with other
franchises i mean that can work that's
super cool when they got to this part i
started thinking it might have been call
of juarez yeah there's a couple of
people like Twitter saying the same
thing as well Lucio your impressions of
this I think first of all go to
celebrate the fact that this was a
genuine surprise yeah true i mean
they've kept this really under wraps
Anubis after not really known for
keeping the ship this ship watertight um
so I'm kind of yeah I'm excited to see
more of it it was weird though I
expected more of a fanfare it is a new
game but we just got this trailer so I'm
excited about seeing it I assume they're
gonna have at least this trailer or some
representative
on the booth to talk about it yeah it
hope so it looks cool I'm also card or
woman yeah Roman good point that
technology spread across all of that
Ubisoft various teams and it's kind of
an interesting take I think Kevin I'm
kind of I like the fact that this is I
don't know the the co-op stuff in FarCry
4 was good fun the idea of expanding
that add almost like the crew where
you've got this mad open world you can
team up with a couple of buddies and I
don't take on mission right all around
the place I'm pretty excited but yeah I
mean I think it's gonna be super fun I
mean I think the downside of course is
that it does remind us of all of the
other ubisoft game yeah we looked at it
and think hey it looks like is this
could this be far cry maybe um and I
think that's the only the only real
drawback at the the specific might have
been a surprise but what this game is I
don't think is actually a surprise at
all yeah whether that doesn't mean it's
not going to be awesome more fun but I
don't think that it makes for much of a
surprise yeah it's crazy to think like
how far removed this is from the
original title of ghost recon as well
it's kind of its it the things they've
done with this franchise been kind of
all over the place a head tattoo yeah
the headset that might be my next tattoo
don't mess that you never know how it
crosses tattooed on her face I feel like
that's something all of our mothers have
told us at some stage you're not and
that's Ghost Recon wildlands that's all
we know about it so far that's our
initial import we literally saw it like
three minutes ago as your fingers
crossed to be more information about
that and we'll have it right here on
gamespot com
you